on passe maintenant aux sujets qu'ils
gagnent m pap et que j'aime que
j'embrasse aussi le joueur pourrait
partir du psg pour aller au real madrid
pour y remédier le psg a décidé
d'augmenter son salaire est de proposer
aux footballeurs une somme énorme
regardez on en parle juste après serait
qu'un le psg via son son investisseur
sans propriétaire qatari propose un
million d'euros par semaine pour garder
kylie ann pape ait fait son coeur
balance entre le real madrid et le paris
saint germain est donc l'émir du qatar
et c'est le tout pour le tout et donc
aurait proposé ce contrat sur deux ans
120 millions d'euros donc c'est 64 5
millions d'euros par an ça fait donc un
million deux cent mille euros par
semaine et ça fait donc 118 euros par
minute
on en envoie nos amis des grandes
gueules tout cas sur rmc
alors c'est j'espère qu'il va rester
quotidienne parce qu'on aime c'est un
joueur incroyable c'est un homme
incroyable je vous le dis il fait
énormément pour les associations c'est
un garçon vraiment d'une gentillesse et
d'une humidité incroyable mais c'est
vrai que ce serait le plus gros salaires
de tous les temps oui c'est un plus gros
salaires de tous les temps alors ça
devient une affaire d'état est un au
qatar parce que l'émir du qatar veut le
garder est en france parce qu'on dit qu
emmanuel macron et l'aurait rencontré et
lui aurait demandé de rester au nom de
la france la france a besoin de vous et
nicolas sarkozy grands supporters du psg
lui aussi fait pression sur lui il
paraît même que valérie pécresse
l'aurait fait voter voter aux primaires
alors le real madrid le real madrid lui
proposait une prime à la signature parce
qu'il est libre de signer de 50 millions
d'euros directement et un salaire de 25
millions sur six ans 150 donc ce package
le qatar est en train de le dépasser en
lui proposant de rester il tente le tout
pour le tout pardon mais qu'est ce qui
est choquant c'est le meilleur joueur du
monde a bien sûr
45 millions d'euros par an et est
exactement le même salaire 1 millions
d'euros cinquième essai mais aujourd'hui
il marque il est là c'est le meilleur
joueur du monde vous vous êtes le
meilleur joueur de france en animateur
d'amour regardez je suis pas tout à fait
à ceux
de la chaîne non non pas du tout moi je
suis d'auxerre
[Rires]
roy c'est également mon ami nasser que
j'adore ce
sera intéressant quand même de voir
parce que effectivement si le psg mais
une somme colossale sur la table et que
lui a toujours dit que son désir absolu
la maintenance était de partir de ce
qu'ils avaient envie de partir et que
son rêve céréales ça va être intéressant
de voir si si il est bien au psg aussi
alors je vous le dis le real proposerait
50 millions d'euros par an de salaire
annuel à killian mbp et le psg lui
proposerait 62,4 millions d'euros par an
c'est à dire et à une broutille de 12
millions can en aérien japonais pour lui
poser sont achetés suffit pour acheter
des mocassins
ya des enjeux sportifs aussi pour lui
bien sûr l année prochaine je pense que
c'est pas l'argent noir et quoi on est
content qu'il reste en ligue 1 pour nous
parce que c'est très bien de le voir en
ligue 1 on est content qu'il paye autant
d'impôts en france m'a
énormément d'atouts en france mais ça
peut être quand même choquant d'entendre
110 euros la minute il ya des gens qui
gagnent même pas 110 euros quand tu vas
toi tu bouges ton démago patrice et 865
me smic n'ont pas la même chose à 110
euros par jour donc c'est punchy à des
gens faut comprendre qu'il ya des gens
qui peuvent être choqués dans 25
meilleures années millions si oui mais
je suis depuis l'annoncé des projets
avec des pommes moi quand j'ai vu ça m'a
despatie quotidien je suis content
qu'ils restent par mes pommes et quand
j'ai parlé avec des gens les gens me
disais mais pourquoi on fait pas autre
chose avec cet argent les gens de villé
janvry en fait mais si on ne choisit ni
jouera pas au psg en fait à bien sûr
j'ai une question pour vous serrez parce
que vous êtes proche de qu'il ya même
appel
vous le connaissez vous nous direz si
vous savez qu'il va rester mais ce que
vous pensez qu'il va rester au psg
franchement je peux pas me viable et il
me l'a jamais dit on en a jamais parlé
ce que je sais c'est que j'espère qu'il
fera le bon choix pour lui voilà je le
souhaite le meilleur je sais que je l
adore vraiment je les adore c'est un mec
vraiment que il est il est incroyable je
les rencontre et je ne connais pas bien
j'ai rencontré deux fois on était à une
soirée ensemble sur rencontre en soirée
voilà où c'est pour toi y est et je
l'adoré bien aussi je les adore vraiment
chez m et non vous avez changé sms quoi
vous avez la soirée là on est une soirée
ensemble c'est un amour on a rigolé mais
je pense moi je sais pas pourquoi je
sens qu'il se sent qu'il veut je sens
qu'il va rester ce sera bien car je sens
qu'il va rester moins cher il ya une
rumeur quand même persistante c'est que
zidane bien au paris st jean et
sa commande j'ai eu quelques infos comme
quoi ce serait pas impossible mais j'ai
choisi d'aménager des infos vraiment de
gens qui sont dans le dur du côté de
zidane qui me vient à cordes alors
j'espère ça serait génial je pense que
si la niant je vois pas qu'il ya ne
partirai jamais mais me voilà donc après
j'ai eu là on espère que les deux seront
là pour l'instant il n'y a rien de fait
avec kids mais voilà en tout cas un
certain bomba qui parce que l'argent il
leur en espagne quand même donc
qu'est-ce qu'il dit lui
qui parte pour nous la france faut pas
qu'ils pas parce que l'argent il ne
touchera quand même en espagne non
content d'autant que ça reste là autant
qu'on se régale avec ses chevaux par ans
à son salaire la douche ou tu sais pas
ce que c'est des deux chevaux pokémon
toucas très sympa
c'est vraiment très très très fort
heureusement que vous êtes là